daniel est un athlète du clavier il est
l'un des rares vérificateur de fait des
déclarations de trump en temps réel un
mensonge
oui vous avez bien entendu il était le
premier à oser utiliser ce terme pour la
plupart des faussetés du président mais
pas pour lui un canadien en sol
américain il s'objecte ouvrit de jacques
chirac deux semaines avant d'être
embauché à sienne dernière dell a
commencé sa carrière de détecteur de
mensonges au toronto star
roni size me faut maintenant employé de
cnn il n'est pas épargné par les
partisans de donald trump
depuis l'élection du président la
vérification de fait par des
journalistes a connu un bond sans
précédent dans le washington post par
exemple on attribue des pinocchio à
certaines déclarations de donald trump
en fonction de l'inexactitude des propos
par l'opprobre le journal souvent
critiqué par la maison blanche à
dépister pas moins de 20000 déclaration
trompeuse ou inexacte c'est une
vingtaine par jour juste cette année
mais à la différence de cnn le mot
mensonge est utilisé très rarement
la fiction sur ces milliers de
vérification de fait daniel dell a dû
quelques rares fois corrigé le tir et
c'est le différencie du président selon
lui c'est un rassemblement il détecte en
moyenne entre 7 et 10 mensonge par jour
ce qui n'est pas la norme dans bien des
médias à assister à la longue la
malhonnêteté politique du président
fonctionne déplore daniel d'elle il ya
quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle
non il ne souhaite pas secrètement un
vainqueur entre joe biden ou donald
trump
il y aura encore un emploi peu importe
le gagnant et les chambres d'ici là la
cadence des détecteurs de mensonge n'est
pas près de ralentir ici frédéric
arnould radio-canada washington